it's a triple shooting in the Northeast
Valley killing the man and injuring two
others tonight police tell us this
happened near North Las Vegas Boulevard
and Craig not far from Nellis Air Force
Base about 5 30 this evening that's
where we find Sasha Loftus now joining
us live Sasha with the latest
information we're getting directly from
police
Brian the shopping center
ing happened behind me is still
completely blocked off as this
investigation continues police say three
people were shot here one a man and his
teens is dead after this shooting again
outside this Jack-in-the-Box restaurant
you see here officers tell us two men
were outside the drive-through window of
that restaurant when they got into an
argument then the suspect reportedly
pulled out a gun and shot the victim
several times he was taken to the
hospital where he later died police say
two women also described as adult
teenagers were shot as well but both are
expected to be okay investigators are
still searching for the suspect tonight
but they don't believe this was a random
situation
well I do not believe this is a random
incident I believe that both these
parties uh knew one another uh prior to
this incident which is what something
going on between the two of them caused
them to get in a fight tonight I do
believe that uh both female victims uh
that were appear to be were in the line
of fire but both of them appeared to
have been with the suspect and the
victim prior to this incident occurring
the man police are searching for is set
to be wearing a black hoodie and gray
sweatpants they say he ran away right
after the shooting no word on which
direction he went back out here live of
course if you have any information you
are asked to call Metro Police or Crime
Stoppers to remain anonymous now as for
the shopping center as I mentioned it is
still completely shut down it's set to
stay shut down rather for a little while
longer into the night as this
investigation continues reporting live
tonight Sasha Loftus 8 News Now